you're doing it no hi my name is grace
helbig if you did not know now you know
your life is different now recently I
have learned about a new mystical
adventure that some people have been
partaking in and by some people I mean
one woman and by mystical adventure I
mean predicting the future with a spare
guess yeah I recently found that there
was a woman named Jemima who lives over
in the UK and she has been predicting
the future using asparagus I did a
little research like 30 seconds yeah
that's what she's been doing she casts
asparagus meaning she tosses asparagus
onto mmm what looks like paper towels
that's have a look at this one first of
all and what is this what does this tell
us that is I think you'll find that's
the May Day and from there she sees what
shapes and patterns the asparagus is
made and she's able to predict the
future there's a letter V and a letter e
which shows that we're going to have a
double celebration
apparently she's the only person out
there doing this and so I thought
obviously I should try doing this I
don't want to step on her toes I don't
want to encroach on her territory I only
want to celebrate the gift that she's
been given and see if I to have such a
gift
[Music]
[Applause]
we have all the necessary tools for this
endeavor some paper towels asparagus
I'm feeling very witchy today should I
do like three predictions like three
casts I'm gonna do one for me no I'll do
one for you will do one for you I'm
gonna make you a believer today predict
the past I think we're gonna stick to
trying to read the future because
nothing ever goes wrong when you try to
predict the future especially because we
all definitely have free will so this
should be easy to do should we start
with you Eliot let's warm up with yours
we got our asparagus no goose is also a
non-believer a little nervous I've been
waiting to do this for a while and I
brought asparagus from Los Angeles down
the palm springs do this she didn't seem
to do this much so I'm gonna maybe throw
a little also I'm not sure if she cooked
the asparagus first I couldn't really
tell and the spears um coming forward
indicate there is really great good news
so we're gonna do this for you Eliot I
want you to focus on your intention just
like tarot cards I'm very much into
usually you shuffle the deck while
someone focuses on the intention that
they want from the reading so I'll
shuffle the asparagus cool I don't know
if she shows how she does this but I've
seen some photos of her throwing these
fergus casting here we go
focusing on Eliot
yes whoa I completely missed the papers
haha but I don't want it I don't want to
mess the reading up so Elliot here is
your cast
now what Jemima seemed to do is she
found some letters and things that stuck
out to her about what she read so I see
an upside down a this way and I'm seeing
a lot of movement sort of this way what
I'm seeing for you Elliot a a for
Avengers I think maybe there's an
Avengers film in your future that's up
to you
I can only okay to struggles that you're
up against like The Avengers
you're gonna face off and you're gonna
have a lot of momentum in your direction
there's also a little wily asparagus out
to the side you're gonna learn a new
language mm-hmm
no that's all I see right now that's all
I see right now but yeah and maybe learn
Spanish whoa wow this does I'm tired
this takes a lot out of you
let's try one for me I'm gonna focus on
my future and oh okay wow we made
progress hitting the paper towel we have
one asparagus that fell on the floor
all of these asparagus is are pointing
at me which makes me feel very connected
to the asparagus it's almost as if the
asparagus is telling me that I have a
future with them I think maybe the
asparagus is telling me that my future
is going to be reading futures with
asparagus obviously I see a little cross
section over here like an X this is my
past I don't need to go back in my past
because asparagus is my future I think
the one on the floor is a positive I
like to see this in a positive thing
like it's by my left foot which makes me
think like oh maybe I'll become a lefty
this year
whoo all right
last prediction that we're doing here
and this is a big one because this is
for you I need you all to focus on your
intentions shuffling the asparagus for
you guys here's your future and three -
whoa okay guys we have a lot to unpack
here here we go
so it's all pointing directly at you
what letters do we have here I see an A
here
perhaps another Avengers film you guys
might be in an Avengers film at least
one of you could potentially be in an
Avengers film I don't know if that's
background working craft services or
some sort of Hemsworth it's all right
here very obviously again all I see is a
big egg which only means one thing
you're all gonna be in an Avengers film
don't want to neglect that there's some
little pieces that have fallen off
obviously some shattered relationships
with your family due to the stress of
filming obviously when you're on a set
like that you're gonna be really
stressed out and away from your loved
ones for a long time and so some
relationships might break and that's for
the best
but I do see Avengers pretty much the
only thing I see for you guys is that
you're gonna be in an Avengers movie I
mean whoo I am exhausted
and I feel like I've done an amazing job
I'm really excited for you guys I know
we're all living in a world where none
of us know what our next steps are but I
feel very certain that these are all of
your next steps I'm a little nervous
that I unlocked a Power deep within me
that I didn't know was festering I know
I've been having some gastrointestinal
issues lately but I don't think it's
that I feel like I've found my truth
with great power comes great
responsibility and I feel very
responsible for letting you all know
that you should quit whatever career
endeavors you're involved in now and
focus solely on your acting Avengers
future one of you out there is gonna be
in an Avengers film if not all of you
out there is gonna be in the next
Avengers film this is powerful stuff
also let it be known this vergis hasn't
been washed cooked or anything so this
is we're all dog and a sparrow mansur
[ __ ] right here all right I need to take
a break I am Zonk time I'm emotionally
drained from all of this thank you guys
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
video you know I know you did I can see
it in this Baraga so I don't even need
to ask you do like it or anything I just
I know other than that I would say I
don't know but clearly I do so